-Now. J.B., you´re gonna
start the game
by pressing "start"
on this buzzer
and drawing a clue
from the top of the pile.
You have to get your teammate
to guess the clue
as quickly as possible.
Then hand the buzzer off
to the person on your right.
You can make
any physical gesture
and say whatever you want,
but you can´t say
any word in the actual clue.
If you´re holding the buzzer
when it goes off,
your team loses the round.
We´ll play three rounds.
Let´s take our positions.
J.B., you´re there.
Jessica, you´re
all the way over there.
I´m sorry to make you
walk over there.
-No, it´s fine.
-Yeah.
All right. Here we go.
J.B., you´ll start the game off.
Press start,
and then draw your clue.
Good luck.
-This is three on two right now.
This is crazy.
-No, no, no, no.
J.B., here we go.
We can do this.
We can make this work.
It´s not three on two.
You guys are teammates.
Oh, it is. Yeah.
You´re right. It is.
[ Laughter ]
I didn´t think about that.
All right. You´re --
-We´re outnumbered.
We´re outnumbered.
-I´m doing the math.
-I know. I´m sorry.
Yeah, exactly. Sorry.
Apologize.
All right. Whew.
Best of luck.
-Let´s go. Come on.
-Whoo!
-All right, all right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Beeps ]
On water.
-Walk on water.
Surf.
-No, uh...
-Jet ski.
-What is it, though?
-Surfboard.
-Whoo!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Okay.
-Oh, take the card.
-Head butt.
Hey! Head butt!
Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Uh...
You can´t mess with my...
[ Laughter ]
It´s a toy.
It´s a toy, and you...
sling it.
-My yo-yo!
-Yes, yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Howls ]
-Uh, a wolf, uh, dog, um...
-I´m a man that turns into one.
-Oh, a werewolf.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Piece of hair
that goes right here.
-A Mohawk.
-Boom!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You suck! You suck!
You can´t put it down.
Oh.
Um...
-Uh, body rock.
Wave. The wave.
-Um...
-Pop and lock. The wave.
-Yes.
[ Buzzer ]
-Ooh!
-Yo, yo!
♫♫
Come on, man.
You know what´s up, man.
That´s the way
to take ´em down, man.
Really -- Unbelievable.
How dare you?
[ Laughter ]
How dare you even question
that that would happen?
[ Laughter ]
You´re in so much trouble, man.
-Okay.
I see how this is.
-Know what´s up, man?
Pop and lock?
-Don´t show him.
[ Beeping ]
-Uh...
German beer thing.
Like, a big beer party
that happens
around this time of year.
-Oh, um...
-Germans. Beers. Lederhosen.
-Oh!
Uh, uh, uh!
-Lederhosen.
-St. Patty´s Day!
[ Laughter ]
-No, it´s got -- it´s got
the name of this month in it.
It´s got the name of this month
in it.
-Uh, uh...
[stammers]
-This month right now.
-Oh, oh!
Oktoberfest!
-Yes!
-Oh, my God!
-Didn´t know Oktoberfest.
Oh, no.
[ Laughter ]
-Come on.
-Okay, it´s, uh --
It´s not an apple,
not an orange, but it´s a...
-A pineapple.
-Yeah, well...
It´s a type of underwear,
like a --
-It´s a -- It´s a --
It´s a banana hammock.
-Yes, it is!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♫Fresh from
the valley of the... ♫
-Um...what?
-♫ Fresh from
the valley of the... ♫
The tall guy.
♫ Fresh from
the valley of the... ♫
-Jolly Green Giant.
-Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh. Oh.
[ Buzzer ]
[ Fog horn plays ]
-What happened?
We´ve got to
give it to her.
-Every time?!
-No, what happened?
What was that?
-No, you got pop and lock
before the buzzer.
This was a --
Fake I.D.
How do you even?
-So, we got the loss
on that one, all right?
This is it.
Whoever wins this,
wins everything.
-Okay.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Dignity,
the most important thing.
-They´re gonna
go down tonight!
You got to go down
tonight!
-Jolly Green Giant?
-I got to live here
with him.
Come on, man.
-Here we go. Here we go.
[ Beeps ]
Come on, partner.
-Okay.
In the Olympics...
-Yes. I love it.
-...they..
-Javelin!
-And they go over the...
-Oh, jump -- pole vault.
-Yes.
-Yeah, I love it.
Love it. Love you.
-Uh, okay.
Uh...legs wide open.
What do they call that?
It´s also the name
of a bird.
-Uh...
-Open. Bird.
-Baby. There´s a baby here.
-Name of a bird.
Means wide open.
If you laying there
with your legs open...
-Uh, a cub -- a --
What was that?
A bird?
-The national bird.
The national bird.
-Eagle. Spread Eagle!
-Yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-All right. Ready.
If you´re really cool and, like,
preppy, you could, like...
-A bow tie.
-You could do this
to your shirt.
A golf shirt.
-Oh.
You pop your collar.
-Oh, yeah.
-Ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh!
In the projects,
we look through --
-Monocle.
[ Buzzer ]
A peephole!
-Oh! He got it!
He got it!
-No, no, no.
No, no, no, no, no.
No, no.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Are you kidding me?!
-Nobody in the projects
has a monocle!
-Has a monocle!
-No, then I said peephole.
-Nobody in the --
[ Laughs ]
Nobody in the projects
has a monocle.
All right.
Thanks to Jessica Alba,
J.B. Smoove, and Tariq.
We´re talking to J.B. after the
break.
Stick around, everybody.
Dude...
[ Laughs ]